bonsoir antoine velimir cousine a donc
réagi cet après midi aux déclarations de
joe biden oui tout à fait dans un
premier temps vladmir poutine a répondu
par une pirouette en renvoyant joe biden
a sa propre attaque en déclarant je cite
que lorsqu'on tente de juger d'autres
gens ou même d'autres pays où d'autres
peuples
on se regarde toujours en quelque sorte
dans un miroir et vladimir poutine ne
s'est pas contenter de simplement
commenté la saillie verbale du président
américain
en retour il a proposé à son homologue
de débattre ensemble en direct et ce
dans les tout prochains jours
écoutez nous ne devons pas échangé dans
le dos de l'autre nous pouvons et nous
devons poursuivre une relation n'était
sûr c'est pas demain
d'ailleurs j'y ai pensé la dernière fois
que nous avons une conversation
téléphonique
l'initiative est venue du président
biden je voudrais proposer au président
buydens poursuivre notre discussion mais
à condition que nous fassions en direct
en ligne comme on dit il s'agirait d'une
discussion ouverte en direct nous
pourrions parler des relations
bilatérales de la stabilité stratégique
et du traitement des conflits régionaux
et il y en a beaucoup
le ghana lequel philippe ou d autres
défis auxquels l'humanité est confrontée
aujourd'hui
j'aurais juste le président russe a
proposé la date de ce vendredi 19 mars
ou bien lundi après le week end
il a également ajouté que des
instructions dans ce sens allait être
donné au ministère des affaires
étrangères la balle est donc maintenant
dans le camp du locataire de la maison
blanche et antoine cette passe d'armes
est aussi lié à la publication d'un
rapport du renseignement américain qui
accuse la russie d'ingérence lors de la
dernière élection présidentielle aux
états unis comment les autorités russes
ont elles réagi
oui bien la diplomatie russe a dans un
premier temps répondu sur la forme sur
cette attaque verbale de joe biden avant
ensuite de répondre sur le fond de cette
nouvelle accusation je vous laisse
écouter l'administration américaine
actuelle ne cesse de surprendre par
l'absurdité de ces déclarations
publiques
je fais référence non seulement aux
attaques contre les dirigeants russes
qui dépasse toutes les limites de la
décence mais aussi aux accusations
absurdes d'ingérence dans les élections
présidentielles de l'année dernière le
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
qui a également rappelé à moscou son
ambassadeur en poste à washington afin
de définir la stratégie à adopter afin
de décider de la suite à donner à cette
affaire et antoine washington qui a
aussi menacé de sanction des entités
impliquées dans le gazoduc north stream
2 oui le chef de la diplomatie
américaine a appelé jeudi dans un
communiqué toutes les entités impliquées
dans le projet de gazoduc à se
désengager immédiatement sous peine de
sanctions américaines
nos passages dénoncer je cite un projet
géopolitique russe visant à diviser
l'europe et affaiblir sa sécurité
énergétique
cette annonce intervient alors même que
les travaux de ce gazoduc russo allemand
achevé à plus de 95% avait justement
repris depuis le mois de février
après de longs mois d'arrêt en raison
déjà de sanctions américaines
merci antoine clairon en direct de
moscou